it's called emoji licious okay what are
your three favorite emojis and can you
act them out for us sure shooting star
Oh ready that one is my favorite emoji
soup whoo let that pink one is that a
good one that's so awkward i hope you
straight up that was like the most
awkward okay that one where that crying
laughing smiling face devil clothes I
tongue out like thing because I just
make that face all the time the tongue
stick out with like the triangle eyes um
it's supposed to be a cookie Oh got it
you know that like i give good that won
by can't i guess he's like little notes
mm-hmm the twins the twin dancing i love
it she's just like really happy what you
say never I don't know what that means
like it was like that don't know is okay
no that was not even close down the
completely housing emoji knows a new
emoji those are calm OG right there I
love the little smiley face with the
hands when I'm like tracks when I'm
trying to be cute so it's like I'll see
you there which one like the one that's
just just the town the phone yeah my
number one emojis is this emoji but you
yeah I mean I have a lot of muscles you
can't see them under my jacket how would
you act out the unicorn I don't know
there we go